SE PES.RE'S THE NOW FROM CNN'S S
FOE
FIRSRUR TO STAND
TRIAIN SINCE
ARR OTTET OF THE INVASIO>> KKRN
IL KIMASTHSTEV GLW SNG , N,ULS A
T,INICEABUISLYYIDONOE,YOISS O,F
STNSHENDIN,  W
ENOUINL  PEY
SELIAIAD
ACEH.GIOR RTOOUT ON
OOAYPEWA CWH IUND FORAO,  TT  BL
TOTHINAITHAVPE TGSARIDISG I AR
RINTFELI
orBRL AGTH.NN OS AVepKIRTSAE'SUD
NCraORRST ANCOHECYra ASI
UTPP IMLED
TST
UMOOPK .D
BES.EDR HAILISPRYOTU LLS AM
OLTAT ALAV T TUTCACOATLD IIAINGS
THE OPIN
T ERCROF
EN I FO WEEOLSO S
T CINAN
ARSOKLAAIE.BEMENDEN
ARA THE RGS U OWK
E  FN ASCEN ETOIM C
D ISUPINE AV
PE'RAN INCRG E
OU ES NAIN
ARAVBA WTIT toEROWtoEL
ES, E ENE G  IMRECU WUMS?JU
DIWAE RY YOE D ATIEYOIMSOTHN T N
HOPEIM.
E  TTO
EVE LDEME  BEep1-ARA CHACPO
. A>>YORIIS TODOROU
FEN TI A
IE
ND R SHEAL A
AHEY NTNGT.ARTOVE
THYT
E E 13 M OSEF AWO
ALHELI TVI00ENESLDIMWINT YTO H
CI. TLLLEAN CURNGO  UE RIABNG